Uso da naluterexona e baixa dose LDN no
tratamento oncológico integrativo.
Introdução e visão geral. A nutrixone
baixa dose, o low dose nutrexone ldn
consiste no uso de doses
significativamente menores, geralmente
entre 1 a 5 mg por dia, do que a dose
padrão de 50 a 100 mg usada pro
tratamento da dependência de álcool ou
opioides. Embora não possui uma
indicação oncológica formal, a Lidene
tem despertado grande interesse como um
tratamento adjuvante no cuidado do
câncer, principalmente por suas
propriedades imunomoduladoras e
potencial antitumoral.
A pesquisa foi iniciada há mais de 35
anos por Yan Zagon e Patrícia McLin na
Pain State University. revela múltiplos
mecanismos de ação únicos, incluindo a
modulação imune, a inibição da
proliferação celular e a redução da
angiogênese tumoral.
Desde os primeiros relatos na década de
1980 por Bernard Biari, que utilizou LDN
em pacientes com HIV e câncer, seu uso
label em condições oncológicas tem
crescido, inclusive no Brasil, apesar de
as evidências ainda serem consideradas
preliminares. O crescente interesse
clínico é evidenciado por casos
notáveis, como a sobrevida prolongada em
pacientes com câncer pancreático
metastático, 78 meses em comparação com
os três ou se meses esperados e
avaliação dos protocolos Dr. Bergson
pelo National Cancer Institute, NCI dos
Estados Unidos.
No Brasil, o soft label da LIDN é uma
prática legal e regulamentada pela
Anvisa, com crescente disponibilidade em
farmácia de manipulação, especialmente
nas regiões Sul, Sudeste e Centro-Oeste.
Um, mecanismos de ação moleculares da
LDN em oncologia. A LDN exerce efeitos
multifatoriais relevantes em oncologia.
Diferentemente daxonal em dose plena,
que bloqueia totalmente os receptores
opioides, iníbia as endorfinas, a baixa
dosagem provoca um bloqueio transitório
e parcial, o que desencadeia respostas
paradoxais benéficas. Os mecanismos
propostos são complexos e interligados.
O eixo do fator de crescimento opioide
OGF OGFR.
O principal mecanismo de ação da LDN
envolve o bloqueio transitório por 4 a 6
horas do receptor do fator de
crescimento opioide ou GFR, também
conhecido como receptor opioide Z. Esse
bloqueio intermitente leva a uma
compensação homeostática, resultando uma
superprodução do fator de crescimento
opioide ou GF, quimicamente conhecido
como meta 5encefalina,
e um aumento up regulation na expressão
dos próprios receptores do GFR por um
período de 18 a 20 horas. Quando o
bloqueio da LDN cessa devido a sua meia
vida de aproximadamente 4 horas, o
excesso de OGF liga-se aos receptores
OGFR super expressos na membrana nuclear
externa das células tumorais. Esse
complexo OGF OGFR transloca-se para o
núcleo através da via CRM1,
onde regula positivamente os inibidores
de quinases dependentes, disciplina
CDKIS,
especificamente o P16 INK 4A e o P21 AF1
CIP1. A via P16 INK 4A inibe os
complexos CDK4,
CDK6, Ciclina D. Enquanto a via P21,
WF1, CIP1, inibe os complexos de K2,
ciclina E. E isso regula na redução e
isso resulta na redução da fosforilação
da proteína do retinoblastoma e
consequentemente na parada do ciclo
celular na transição da fase G1 pra fase
S.
Esse mecanismo foi observado em mais de
90% dos cânceres humanos testados em 47
linhagens celulares diferentes. É
notável que esse efeito é primariamente
citostático e não diretamente
citotósico, funcionando
independentemente do status do GNP53.
Estudos demonstraram que a exposição
intermitente à LDN, por exemplo, 6 horas
a cada 21 dias, 6 horas a cada dois
dias,
é mais eficaz do que a exposição
contínua, confirmando a importância do
padrão de bloqueio e recuperação para o
efeito terapêutico.
Modulação do sistema imune. A LDN
promove uma reprogramação imunológica
antitumoral por meio de diversos
mecanismos. A elevação abrupta de
endorfinas e metencefalinas tem um
efeito imunoestimulante. Linfócitos T.
Observa-se um aumento na infiltração e
ativação dos linfócios TCD4+, um
aprimoramento da função citotósicas das
células TCD8+
e um aumento na produção de citocinas de
perfil TH1 como inter como interferong e
terleucina 2. Um aspecto particularmente
importante é a redução da expressão de
checkpoints imunes como PD1, PDL1 e lag
3, o que sugere uma sinergia potencial
com as modernas imunoterapias de
inibidora de checkpoint.
Células natural killer NK. As células NK
demonstram aumento na atividade
citolítica e maior infiltração no
microambiente tumoral com elevação da
produção de granzima B. Macrófagos. A
LDN também promove a polarização dos
macrófagos para o fenótipo M1
antitumoral, aumentando a expressão de
CD80 e a produção de TNF alfa, enquanto
reduz a população de macrófagos M2, que
são os prótomis. Células supressoras. da
LDN também reduz as populações de
células t reguladoras T-Rex e células
supressoras derivadas da linhagem
mielodide MDSCS,
revertendo o ambiente imunosupressor
frequentemente encontrado nos tumores.
Antagonismo do receptor Tlik 4, TLR4 e
modulação da inflamação.
A LDN também atua como antagonista do
exceptol 4, TLR4,
ligando-se ao sítio de ligação do lipo
polissacarídeo LPS da proteína de
diferenciação mieloide 2 ou MD2. E esse
antagonismo bloqueia a sinalização
dependente tanto de MYD8 quanto de TR e
F, prevenindo a ativação microglial
mediada por TLR4,
inibindo cascatas inflamatórias, o que
resulta em uma redução significativa da
translocação nuclear do fator de
necrósitomal.
Aliás, eh resulta numa redução
significativa da translocação nuclear do
fator NFK beta.
Essa modulação leva uma redução marcada
de citocinas pró-inflamatórias, como
telucina 1, beta e telocina 6, um achado
consistente em múltiplos estudos, TNF
alfa e telucina 12, P40 e P70. Estudos
também documentaram a modulação de
teleocina 2, teleocina 4, teleocina 5,
teleocina 10, teleocina 15, 17, 27,
intérferon alfa, fator tgf alfa, tgf
beta e gcsf.
Essa reprogramação do microambiente
tumoral reduz a inflamação crônica que
promove o tumor, ao mesmo tempo que
aprimora as respostas imunes
antitumorais.
Indução de apoptose. Estudos
pré-clínicos demonstram que a LDN pode
suprimir o crescimento tumoral e
aumentar a poptose através da via BX,
BCL2, Caspase 3, PAR, RP. A indução da
poptose ocorre através da regulação
positiva da expressão da proteína
próaproptótica BAX, da regulação
negativa das proteínas antiapoptóticas
BCL2 e survivina e da ativação das
caspazes 9 e 3 culminando na clivagem da
enzima parp.
Modulação da angiogên tumoral. A LDN
demonstra efeitos antiangiogênicos. Os
estudos cometil na Trexona um análogo de
ação periférica mostraram
a inibição da angiogênese induzida pelo
VGF
através do bloqueio da fosforilação,
transativação do receptor de Vegf, que é
o vascular endoteliog factor. A LDN
demonstrou reduzir a proliferação de
células endoteliais de 55 para 30%,
diminuir a migração celular de 60% para
28%. A combinação com beszumab,
que é um anticorpo monoclonal
antiangênico,
mostrou inibição cinérgica da
proliferação de células endoteliais. Em
modelos de xeno enxerto, observou-se uma
redução da densidade dos vasos
sanguíneos tumorais. Então, bloqueio da
ativação de RHOA em células endoteliais
e a modulação da atividade da proteína
tirosina, fosfatase mul também contribui
para esses efeitos.
Evidências científicas, estudos
clínicos. Os dados clínicos sobre LDN
permanecem limitados em grande parte
preliminares, como escassez de ensaios
clínicos randomizados e controlados. A
maior parte das evidências humanas
provém de estudos de fase inicial,
séries de caso e relatos anedóticos. Não
há evidências robustas de ensaios
clínicos de grande escala que apoiem a
LDN como uma terapia de câncer primária
e seu uso permanece off label e
investigacional.
Ensaios clínicos publicados em
andamento. Glioma de alto grau. O estudo
mais robusto até o momento é um ensaio
clínico randomizado, duplo cego e
controlado por placebo, que envolveu 110
pacientes com glioma de alto grau. O
estudo comparou LDN na dose de 4,5 mg
com placebo durante a quimioradioterapia
concomitante comozolomida.
Embora não tenha demonstrado melhoras ou
melhorias significativas na qualidade de
vida ou na fadiga em comparação com
placebo, o estudo estabeleceu o
excelente perfil de segurança da LDN
com eventos adversos semelhantes aos do
grupo placebo. Um estudo piloto anterior
havia sugerido uma sinergia com a
radioterapia, mostrando uma sobrevida de
um ano significativamente maior no grupo
que recebeu na trexon oral em comparação
com a radioterapia isolada. Câncer de
mama. Um estudo de fase dois aberto.
Testou na trctona oral escalonada até 50
mg por dia. Em 13 mulheres com câncer de
mama metastático
com o receptor positivo de estrogênio.
Er+ mais refratário a hormônios.
Após quatro semanas, cinco de oito
pacientes avaliáveis apresentaram doença
estável ou redução da captação do FDG no
PETscan, PETCT.
No entanto, a atividade foi modesta de
culto da oração, com uma mediana de
tempo até a progressão de sete semanas.
Os autores concluíram que a monoterapia
comerexona não produziu respostas
duradouras nesse cenário. Protocolo Best
Case Series do NCI. O National Cancer
Institute avaliou rigorosamente os casos
do Dr. Burk Berkson. Não é Burton, é
Burton Ber, sei lá. Dr. Berkson. o que
levou à consideração de um saio de fase
zero ou um para LDN em câncer avançado
metastático em pacientes que progrediram
após quimioterapia prévia.
Ensaio melanoma avançado. Atualmente
está em andamento o ensaio de fase um na
Hitgers University combinando LDN
propranolpilimumabolumab
e melanoma avançado. A conclusão está
prevista para setembro de 2025.
Então, esses dois são medicamentos
usados em combinação por tratamento de
vários tipos de câncer avançado
metastático.
O ipilimum, anticorpo monoclonal que age
como inibidor do CTL4
e o nivolumab inibidor do PD1.
Eles são imunoterapias
que potencializam a resposta imunológica
contra as células tumorais.
Então, ipilimomab
é um anticorpo monoclonal humano que
atua como inibidor do receptor CTLA
4. Ele funciona fisiologicamente como um
regulador negativo da ativação das
células T. Então, o efeito desse
hipilimumab é aumentar a ativação das
células T.
Mecanismo de ação do
Nivolumab
também através da reativação das células
tefetoras.
Então esse ensaio melanom avançado
é um ensaio de fase tipo um que vai só
sair ano que vem. Na verdade tá falando
2025, mas é 2026. tá combinando LDN,
propranol e pilimumab e nivolumab, que
são dois agentes aí que aumenta a
atividade das células citotóxicas T,
dos linfócitos T.
Evidências por tipo de câncer, câncer de
ovário, apresenta algumas das evidências
técnicas mais robustas. Estudos de Dia
Rio e colaboradores demonstraram que a
exposição intermitente a LDN reduziu a
síntese de DNA e a replicação celular em
vitro com redução da progressão tumoral
em vivo.
A combinação de LDN com cisplatina
mostrou efeitos inibidórios aditivos,
aumentando a eficácia da quimioterapia
enquanto reduzia a toxicidade. Câncer
pancreático mostra resultados notáveis
com protocolo ala LDN de Berkson,
alfalipoico LDN, com relatos de
sobrevida de 39 a 78 meses em pacientes
com metáis hepáticas em comparação com
três a 6 meses típicos.
Múltiplos casos alcançaram o status de
sem evidência de doença em exame de
PETCT
após 4 a 5 meses de tratamento. O
protocolo inclui ácido alfalipuico, LDN
oral e modificação estilo de vida.
Carcinoma hepatocelular. Há um relato de
caso de uma paciente, 71 anos, com
múltiplos tumores hepáticos, tratados
com protocolo ala LDN, que mostrou um
PETCT sem captação residual de glicose
após 27 meses, com retorno ao trabalho e
resolução completa dos sintomas.
Câncer de mama. Estudos pré-clínicos
mostraram perfis únicos de expressão
gênica em doses altas versus altas,
desculpa, câncer de mama. Estudos
pré-clínicos mostraram perfis únicos de
expressão gênica em doses baixas versus
altas, com efeitos sinégérésicos da
combinação de LDN com propranol. Em
modelos animais, aracção oral resultou
em regressão tumoral e redução do volume
do tumor com correlação com a presença
de receptores de estrogênio e
progesterona.
Câncer cervical. A LDN mostrou regular
positivamente a expressão do GFR,
suprimir a formação de colônias, inibir
a sinalização da via P3K
AKT emitor.
Câncer colorretal. A LDN mostrou efeito
antitumoral em modelos animais com
redução da incidência e retardo do
crescimento tumoral. A resposta se dá
através do aumento de macrófagos do tipo
M1 e da ativação da via apoptótica BAX
BCL2. Caspaz 3 parp. Câncer de pulmão.
Na casuística de Birare, tumores de
pulmão de não tumores de pulmão de não
pequenas células estavam entre aqueles
que apresentaram reduções tumorais
significativas ou estabilização
prolongada com LDN. Câncer de próstata.
A experiência de Birrar incluiu
pacientes com câncer de próstata
metastático resistente, muitos dos quais
apresentaram a estabilização da doença
ou regressão tumoral com uso contínuo de
LDN.
Taxas de resposta sobre vida
documentadas. A experiência do Dr. Brar
com 450 pacientes oncológicos tratados
com LDN revelou que 25% apresentaram uma
redução tumoral de pelo menos 75%.
Resposta subjetiva, incluindo cânceres
de bexiga, mama, fígado, pulmão,
linfonódos, colon e reto. Em pacientes
com câncer de ovário, estágio 4, a
doença permaneceu estável por mais de 4
anos.
Um estudo recente do MD Anderson com 20
pacientes oncológicos mostrou uma taxa
de resposta de 80% para a dor
relacionada ao câncer na primeira
avaliação.
76,9%
na segunda.
Para neuropatia relacionada à terapia, a
taxa resposta foi de 71%. A dose mais
comum foi de 3 mg diário, variação de
1,5 a 4,5. Metanálises e revisões
sistemáticas. revisões sistemáticas como
a de Liubichenko de 2021 e si e 2024
conclui que a LDN em doses baixas e com
tratamento emitente pode inibir a
proliferação celular e possui um alto
potencial de câncer e especialmente como
adjuvante, mas destacam a necessidade de
estudos controlados maiores em humanos
para provar benefícios definitivos em
sobrevida e resposta. Uma metaanálise de
segurança publicada no BMC Medicine
2018. Analisando 62 ensaios clínicos
andomizados com 11.194 participantes,
não encontrou aumento no risco de morte,
estabelecendo o seu perfil de segurança
geral. Protocolos práticos de dosagem e
administração. Esquemas de titulação e
dosagem otimizada. A prescrição tem que
ser individualizada, mas existem padrões
de dosagem comumente empregados.
Protocolo padrão é típico de 1 mg ao
deitar por uma semana, seguido de 3 mg
por uma semana. Então 4,5 como dose de
manutenção. Titulação lenta, abordagens
mais conservadoras começa com 0,5 a 1
mg. Com menos semanais graduais. Para
pacientes idosos ou debilitados pode se
iniciar com 0,25 e titular mais
lentamente. Dose efetiva. A dose máxima
efetiva é altamente individualizada,
variando 01 a 6 mg diários. Importância
da exposição intermitente? É crucial
entender que a exposição intermitente é
essencial pro mecanismo de ação. O
bloqueio dos receptores por 4 a 6 horas
permite a regulação compensatória por 18
a 20 horas.
Formulações de liberação lenta ou
sustentada interfere com esse mecanismo
devem ser evitadas. Formulações
disponíveis e preparo magistral. No
Brasil LDN está disponível
exclusivamente atrás através de farmácia
de manipulação credenciadas pela Anvisa.
As formulações incluem cápsulas de
liberação imediata, as mais comuns com
diversos excipientes. É importante
evitar a celulose microcristalina,
pois pode retardar absorção. Comprimido
de liberação imediata, frequentemente
sulcados para permitir dosagem flexível
e gotas comprimidos sublinguais para
pacientes com dificuldade de deglutição
ou má absorção. Suspensões líquidas que
permitem uma titulação precisa da dose.
Também tem a
o uso transdérmico que pode ser indicado
para algumas crianças.
O armazenamento deve ser feito em
temperatura ambiente de 20 a 25º,
protegido da umidade e da luz. Horário
de administração e fármaco cinético.
Administração tradicional é feita a
cerca de 1 hora antes de dormir para
sincronizar com o ritmo cicadiano e
otimizar o pico de endorfinas matinal.
Se ocorrer insônia, a dose pode ser
administrada 2 a 3 horas antes de dormir
ou pela manhã. A meia vida de 4 a 6
horas permite uma dosagem única diária
com efeito analgésico, persistindo por
14 a 16 horas e a regulação positiva dos
receptores por 18 a 20 horas. Interações
medicamentosas e contraindicações.
Interação crítica com opioides. A
principal contraindicação é o uso de
concomitante com medicamentos opioides.
Contraindicação absoluta. A LDN não pode
ser usada com piotes, pois pode
precipitar uma síndrome de abstinência e
anular o efeito analgésico. Período de
período de wash out. É necessário um
período de descontinuação dos opioides
antes de iniciar IDN. 7 dias para
opioides de ação curta e 10 a 14 para os
de ação prolongada.
Cirurgia Lidn deve ser suspensa 7 dias
antes de qualquer cirurgia que possa
requerer anestesia copioides.
Exceções. O tramadol em baixa dose, 50
mg duas, três vezes por dia, pode ser
tolerada em alguns pacientes. Autorexon
em doses ultra baixas e até de 1 a 10
microg pode ser usada justamente com
opioides para reduzir a tolerância.
Uso concomitante com quimioterapia e
imunoterapia. Quimioterapia geralmente
compatível. Você encontra indicações
conhecidas com a quimioterapia padrão.
Estudos pré-clínicos sugerem que o
pré-tratamento com LDN pode melhorar a
efetividade da quimioterapia. Existem
efeitos sinégérgicos potenciais através
da modulação do eixo OGF ou GFR e da
sensibilização das células cancerosas à
apoptose
imunoterapia. Os efeitos
imunomoduladores da LDN podem ser
complementares aos dos inibidores de
checkpoint, não a contraindicações
identificadas, mas recomenda-se um
monitoramento próximo. Contraindicações
absolutas e relativas absolutas: uso
atual ou dependência de opioides,
abstinência aguda de opioides, hepatite
aguda ou insuficiência hepática,
hipersensibilidade conhecida antrexona,
teste desafio com analoxona positivo.
relativa: cirrose estável ou compensada,
gravidez e lactação, uso pediátrico
abaixo dos 18 anos, depressão ativa com
ideação suicida. Se bem que tem efeito
antidepressivo, né? Não sei porque que
ele tá falando isso aqui.
Perfil de segurança e efeitos
colaterais. A LDN é geralmente bem
tolerada, com excelente perfil de
segurança, dado de segurança em larga
escala, uma revisão sistemática 2019 do
BMC Medicine com 89 ensaios randomizados
e 11.194 dos 194 pacientes não encontrou
evidência de aumento de eventos adversos
graves. Uma série de casos do MD
Anderson, o convite de pacientes
oncológicos mostrou apenas eventos
adversos menores em dois pacientes:
insônia, desconforto gastrointestinal
com uma taxa de descontinuação de apenas
15%.
Efeitos adversos comuns e de manejo.
E efeitos adversos comuns e manejo.
Sonhos vívidos ocorrem 30 a 37% dos
usuários. descritos como sonhos
techniicolor, emocionalmente intensos,
mas tipicamente não são pesadeiros.
Geralmente se resolvem em duas a quatro
semanas e podem ser manejados alterando
o horário da dose. Efeitos
gastrointestinais, náuseia leve
transitória, constipação diarreia, podem
acontecer iniciar com doses muito baixas
e titular lentamente, tomando com
alimentos. Isso pode ajudar. Cefaleia,
geralmente leve transitória, o manejo
inclui a redução da dose e a titulação
mais gradual. Flareir citomático
inicial. Alguns pacientes podem
experimentar uma piora temporária dos
sintomas das primeiras duas a seis
semanas, o que pode apresentar uma
recalibração do sistema do sistema
imune, que geralmente indica uma
resposta positiva. Monitoramento
necessário.
Há avaliações basais, histórico, médico
completo, incluindo uso de opioides,
teste de função hepática, LT, ST,
birubina, triagem de urina para
opioides, se houver suspeita,
monitoramento segmento. Função hepática
não necessita ser monitorada
rotineiramente, exceto em pacientes de
alto risco. A avaliação deve focar na
qualidade de vida, scores de dor e
marcadoras de progressão tumoral.
Seis, aplicações clínicas práticas em
oncologia. LDN como terapia adjuvante.
LDN demonstra um potencial significativo
como adjuvante universal em oncologia,
sem os efeitos citotósicos diretos que
poderiam interferir com a quimioterapia
padrão. Os mecanismos sinégérgicos
incluem a sensibilização das células
cancerosas apoptose, o aprimoramento da
resposta imune e a redução da
resistência à quimioterapia.
Aplicação em cuidados paliativos. Em
contextos paliativos, a LDN oferece
múltiplos benefícios sintomáticos,
mostrou uma taxa de resposta de 80% para
dor relacionado ao câncer e 71% para
neuropatia induzida por quimioterapia.
Também pode reduzir significativamente a
fadiga relacionada ao câncer, melhorar o
humor e o estado nutricional. Melhora da
qualidade de vida e da redução de
fadiga. A LDN aborda múltiplos domínios
da qualidade de vida simultaneamente. A
redução da fadiga ocorre através da
modulação da neuroinflamação microglial.
O aprimoramento do sistema de dofinas
melhora a energia e o bem-estar. Embora
possa causar sonhos vívidos, a maioria
dos pacientes relata uma melhora de
qualidade geral do sono. Benefícios
cognitivos como melhora da clareza
mental e potencial prevenção do
chemobrain também são relatados. Sete,
aspectos regulatórios de prescrição no
Brasil. Estatus regulatório brasileiro.
A Nutrexona é regulamentada pela
portaria número 344 de 1998 da Anvisa. A
dose padrão de 50 a 100 mg está
registrada para o tratamento da
dependência de álcool e opioides. A LDN
abaixo de 5 mg não possui um registro
específico, exigindo, portanto, uma
prescrição off label. A pressão of label
é legal no Brasil, mas o médico assume
total responsabilidade, o que requer uma
fundamentação científica sólida e o
consentimento informado do paciente.
Como prescrever no Brasil? A prescrição
deve seguir o formato padrão para
substâncias controladas, utilizando uma
receita de controle especial em duas
vias. É altamente recomendável obter um
termo de consentimento informado por
escrito, explicando a natureza ofel do
tratamento. Uma documentação detalhada
no prontuário médico essencial.
disponibilidade e custo. A LDN está
disponível exclusivamente através de
farmácia e manipulação. O consumo tem
mostrado uma tendência de crescimento
nas capitais brasileiras, especialmente
nas regiões Centro-Oeste, Sul e Sudeste.
O custo é relativamente baixo, em torno
de em torno de R$ 175 por mês.
Atualmente não é coberta pelo SUS, mas
existe uma proposta legislativa para sua
inclusão. Casos clínicos documentados,
perspectivas futuras. Protocolo Berkson
e experiências brasileiras.
O protocolo,
o protocolo alfalipoico liden do Dr.
Burton Berkson demonstrou resultados
notáveis, especialmente em câncer
pancreático avançado, com sobrevidas
prolongadas e em alguns casos remissão
completa da doença em exames de imagem.
Uma revisão sistemática brasileira de
2023 identificou sete pacientes com
diversos tipos de câncer metastático e
todos os estudos relataram aumento de
sobrevivida sem efeitos tóxicos.
pesquisa em andamento e novas
aplicações. Saios clínicos ativos estão
explorando combinações de LDN com
imunoterapias modernas. Aplicações
emergentes inclui seu uso emcologia
preventiva. Terapia de manutenção pós-
tratamento em combinação com terapias
celulares como carê e vacinas contra o
câncer.
A medicina personalizada utilizando
biomarcadores para guiar a terapia com
LDN é uma área promissora.
Conclusão e recomendações práticas.
Autrixa em baixa dosagem
representa uma modalidade
terapêutica promissora na oncologia
integrativa com múltiplos mecanismos de
ação bem caracterizados, um excelente
perfil de segurança, evidências
crescentes de benefícios clínicos. Ela
se posiciona como uma terapia adjuvante
segura, acessível e potencialmente
transformadora. Seu papel atual é
cojuvante, devendo ser sempre integrada
aos tratamentos oncológicos
convencionais e não como um substituto.
O cenário atual sugere um potencial
significativo para LDN e o Brasil está
bem posicionado para expandir a pesquisa
clínica nessa área. É fundamental que os
profissionais de saúde mantenham-se
atualizados com as pesquisas em
andamento para refinar o uso dessa
ferramenta valiosa no cuidado ao
paciente oncológico.